[Musique]
dans ce gymnase de szeged à 10 km de la
frontière serbe
l'entraînement a démarré à l'aube
chasseurs frontaliers c'est le nom
officiel d'un nouveau corps de la police
hongroise
objectif numéro 1 du gouvernement de
viktor orban
la chasse aux migrants
cours d'autodéfense maniement des armes
et techniques d'arrestation sont au
programme kitty était vendeuse dans une
boulangerie avant de se porter
volontaires à l'issue de sa formation de
six mois
elle ira assister les quelques 10000
policiers et militaires déjà déployés à
la frontière
financièrement c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant que mon ancien travail mais
c'est aussi plus stable en tant
qu'apprenti je gagne l'équivalent de 470
euros sans compter les primes quand je
travaillais en boulangerie je gagnais
330 euros environ l'interview de kitty
se fait sous le contrôle de sa
hiérarchie
aucune question politique n'est autorisé
bonjour à tous force et performances
repos prenez place
l'objectif de la police nationale est de
recruter trois mille chasseurs
frontaliers pour atteindre ce chiffre
la police nationale mobilise les polices
régionales ce sont elles qui assurent le
recrutement et la formation des
candidats remplissant les critères
l'objectif final est de garantir un
meilleur maintien de l'ordre et apporter
plus de sécurité au pays et pour
empêcher les migrants de traverser la
hongrie le gouvernement a érigé une
clôture le long de la frontière avec la
serbie et la croatie
longue de 175 km équipée de caméras
elle a coûté près de 900 millions
d'euros un coût amplement justifiée
selon ce membre fondateur du fides le
parti du premier ministre viktor orban
on a pu voir en europe de l'ouest ce qui
est arrivé ces deux trois dernières
années la plupart des terroristes sont
des migrants c'est une évidence
il n'y a pas de débat à ce sujet
bruxelles est chargé de répartir les
migrants dans tous les pays mais ils ne
prennent pas en compte les conséquences
que cela va avoir pour l'europe
d'autre part il ne fixe pas de limite à
l'accueil des réfugiés
est ce que ce sera un million de
migrants parente 10 millions en deux ans
cinq ans six ans un point de vue sur les
migrants qui n'est pas partagé par tous
vous pensez vraiment que la question des
migrants c'est la question la plus
importante aujourd'hui en hongrie
la hongrie se vante d'avoir
drastiquement diminué le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile grâce à sa clôture
anti migrants persona non grata sur le
territoire maillard ahmed h en a fait
l'amère expérience ce syrien a été
condamné à dix ans de prison pour avoir
tenté de franchir la frontière en 2015
accusé de terrorisme
après avoir lancé trois pierres sur la
police qui empêchait les migrants de
passer il a fait appel de la décision
le tribunal se réunit donc nouvelle fois
ma question est de savoir si l'accusé
reconnaît les faits qui lui sont
reprochés
je tiens à le dire en toute transparence
je rejette formellement ces accusations
en hongrie le système judiciaire est
sous la coupe du pouvoir exécutif
juste après les émeutes qui ont éclaté
en 2015 à la frontière serbo-croate
tous les politiciens hongrois ont
condamné ahmed h et l'on qualifié de
terroriste donc il est tout à fait
évident qu'il y avait une grande
pression politique sur la procédure et
sur la cour autre cible du gouvernement
les ong une loi les oblige désormais à
déclarer toutes leurs ressources
financières venant de l'étranger
les noms des donateurs seront listés sur
ainsi publié par l'exécutif
une loi qui n'est pas sans conséquence
amnesty international n'accepte pas de
dons provenant des états donc nous
dépendons largement de petits dons
individuels et nous constatons que
certains donateurs ont désormais peur de
donner pour ne pas entrer en conflit
avec le gouvernement hongrois
l'idée principale qui régit la proche du
gouvernement c'est que tous ceux qui
n'entrent pas dans la droite ligne du
gouvernement et contre l'intérêt de la
nation
les journalistes indépendants sont aussi
dans le collimateur du victor ban une
loi oblige les médias à s'enregistrer
auprès des autorités et à produire des
sujets équilibré le gouvernement
s'attaque également à l'enseignement
supérieur à travers l'université
d'europe centrale qu'il veut fermer à
six mois des prochaines élections la
dérive autoritaire du premier ministre
hongrois ne semble pas prête de
s'arrêter